this is a production of cornell
university
okay so bob torre is the owner and
operator of nook and cranny farm in
brooklyn dale new york
cooking crane is a four acre diversified
intensive organic petrol farm that
serves an 85 member csa and attends
three weekly farmers market in the
ithaca area
bob earned his phd in plant path
and in addition to farming bob is a high
school teacher teaching chemistry and
sustainable lag
so i welcome you bob thanks for joining
us and look forward to this session on
strategies for small farms
spare the intro why because i think
brian did a nice job
telling me a little bit about what we do
here um
it's a pretty
tight place and we grow very intensively
and that really dictates a lot of the
management practices
that we use here so
i'm going to tell you a little bit about
some
soil management practices and
tools that we use on the farm
and then of more specifically about
a sarah funded
farmer sarah grant for
researching reduced tillage and
tarping with potato firm so i'll get
into first here some
management techniques so um
we're
trying to reduce village increasingly
and our primary tillage tool
is we just use dcs tractors a bunch of
implements but primary tillage we use
are on pillar attachment
so i have a couple pillars one
that's just tiller without
the depth control and then on the right
is the picture of a different pillar
attachment that has called the precision
depth roller so that
allows you to carefully set how deep the
times go and um we can we can pretty
carefully reduce how much we disturb
soil so the tiller alone i tend to use
in the beginning of the season and
especially for incorporating um
mowed down cover crops and it's much
better with soil potentially wet
come about june we're pretty much
recycling beds um so at that point and
it's dryer um with the precision depth
roller it worked much better and we
could really more carefully reduce how
much
spillage happens so um they use that
from about june on throughout the season
so um here's another really important
tool on our very small scale and and uh
we use a weak whacker a tremendous
amount it might seem kind of ridiculous
to soil management tools but
uh using the weed backer allows us to
not do anything to disturb the soil so
um we use it well when we're working on
particular beds they're 7500 foot long
three foot wide
to get rid of cover crops if we want to
just work on a particular single bed and
then also throughout the season to
reduce weeds and get rid of plant debris
but we can we can
cut the the cover crop or the weeds all
the way down to the soil surface so that
we almost don't have to do another pass
with a
tiller
before we plant into the bed again and
at the end of the season before we cover
crop um we don't really fill beds at
that point much at all we just
blaze them with either the weed whacker
or a cloud mower and then broadcast uh
cover crop speed
so
we do on larger swaths and with mature
cover crop use a soil mower attachment
for the dcf
and um and it works really great but
it's a little bit difficult to work on
our on our tight scale here at this farm
um
so here are some uh
soil management practices that
we really focus on throughout the season
um
the great majority of our beds are
covered throughout the growing season
either with well pretty much every
single thing we transplant is is mulched
either with hay
or with landscape fabric
and then in addition to that
we also hate all of these pathways at
least once so we have three foot beds
and there's a one foot pathway that one
quarter of the farm is getting
mulched with hay each season
and it really prevents weeds from
growing in the in the pathway which is
like a very obvious benefit but but
overall just adding to our organic
matter and
allows
some resiliency and dry summer
for sure
so at the end of the season come about
mid august
um
all the way into november we're really
focusing on expiring the growing crop in
the bed and uh keeping it covered and
hopefully with a living cover so in the
beginning of that process in august and
through september we're broadcasting um
winter rides and field team knicks you
can see on the left and we're pretty
much doing individual beds at a time
whenever the crop is finally harvested
by about october it's not as practical
anymore to be seeding tea so we're just
using winter ride but we often uh
depending on the location of the bed or
how dry it seems to be at that time we
also put down some hay on top of the
variety and then by the end of october
and through november as beds are expired
we don't cover crop anymore that's too
late but we just covered with hay
this is a particular
issue that i think is is a pretty
important whenever you're growing in
high tunnel
if somebody probably realizes that but
if they're covered for years the
increase in
uh salts on the surface of poop house
soils can be um it can be visible it can
and it's like reducing how well things
grow so there are a couple things we do
try to mitigate validity in soil um this
hoop house on the left is posts are
driven in the ground so we take the
plastic off every three four years and
leave it off for a whole season and that
allows rain water to wash some of the
salts out of it
uh two of our other goof houses are
modular and essentially mobile so we
take them down every season and move
them and there are primary tomato pepper
food houses
it allows us to keep a good rotation but
also to have fresh ground grow the
tomatoes in
each year
and then also um
in all the hoop houses you can try to
preferentially use rain water it seems
like it'd be hard to actually catch
enough we have to fix coop 2000 but in
this past year was no problem so i have
a bunch of these 300 gallon
food grade
water catchment
containers set up around our barn in our
house
and uh with a good quarter inch
brainstorm the half inch at most that
can fill these things with 300 gallons
of rain water and have six or 900
gallons of rain water pump out into the
hoop house so it's it's plumbed right
into the irrigation line goes out to the
hoop house depending on the season we
need to do overhead water or we set up
their clients in office houses too so
it's keeping rain water as opposed to
well water uh going into the to the hoop
house
for watering
um next couple slides are a few
uses of tarps that we've been
working into using tarps
in the past few years um
and seeing their benefit and trying to
find useful applications for them
so one thing we did this past year was
we had a field off site that we had
cover crops a year before so we parked
it it has the ride growing pretty
abundantly throughout may he tarped
against the may
left the tarpon with a black carpet the
picture here doesn't actually show the
car left it on for two and a half weeks
and that did a really good job of
terminating that rise you can see this
picture uh and then a strip filled some
swaps into it and then planted winter
squash and and had the winter squash all
planted into landscape fabric and and
all the sandbags were right there so it
was
a particularly effective use of tarping
we had sand back there because we had a
potato experiment i'll tell you about
in a few minutes
and then here is um
another application of parts that i'm
particularly
excited about how
well it seems to have worked so
um hoop houses all have freeze in the
fall greens are done detargeted
november december and as soon as we're
done harvesting then we may go in with
weed whacker and just uh
blaze it down a little bit but then put
a tarpon over it and leave the tarpon
over the winter and um that maintains
some moisture in that soil that
otherwise
these hoof houses can be really deadly
dry come march and april when we want to
press down again
so this past year i tried uh to be
solarized it was clear plastic
from november until
like the end of february and then we put
on um
now i'm sorry at the end of january in
the beginning of february we put a black
black over it and then left that on for
four to five weeks and i just take up
took off uh both the black and the clear
plastic this past weekend and then we
planted that entire hoop house
with carrots and uh it was like the
perfect moisture bubble in there it's
really great and there
really aren't many weeds at all
some
didn't look like much germinated over
the winter but it seems to do a very
good job of taking care of the chickpeas
that's always a problem and who's house
so the last part of
my talk is uh i'm just going to tell you
about this fair funded uh research
project that
ryan and i worked on
this past year so we grow um
potatoes
to surf our csa
pretty substantial amount we can't
really fit it onto our main farm
property with any reasonable rotation
and it doesn't have uh it doesn't
require the real high-end soils that we
have here and careful
cultivation and management so we tend to
grow them on off-site uh fallow seals
that we ran and this picture shows
generally what these fields look like
when we start working with them i rent
some landscapes
typically a lot of perennials so and
i've been doing this for several years
and we used some combination of strips
well moist strip fill potatoes heavy
mulching and then we wanted to try and
do some carbs into this that's to really
um
up our gain with re-suppression and also
carefully
track yields and how much labor we use
looking at both uh tarps and mulches in
in conjunction with each other
so this is uh the essence of our
experiment we were looking to see if
tarps or mulch or a combination of two
would work out the best for
our
market scale potato growing operations
this again their
funded research
so
okay here
is a field layout for
our potato
tart mulch experiment the quarter acre
60 by 200 feet
um we started planting this in well in
the fall of
2020
we mowed it down to the ground
uh actually twice and then broadcast
zero variety pretty thick
and also put down 50 delta a over the
top of the cover crop seeds left it over
the winter it's growing nicely in the
spring
and then this field we divide it into
three different plots
so one part would just be
uh one third of it would just be mulched
and the center
would be both tarp and mulch
and the hay mulch
so in the beginning of may
we went in and um
and put rotary puffers i'll show you
pictures of all this in a moment and the
potatoes would be planted into the
rotary club furrows and put a tarp down
in two of the pot so left this for four
weeks and then a month later took the
tarp off
and in the mulch only plot we had to mow
down the mature cover crop put rotary
furrows in and then planted the entire
place with the data
another month after that
uh came back cultivated build and then
mulched two thirds of the
uh of the entire
area
uh and we didn't really do much of
anything it's pretty low management all
season until we start harvesting from
september so
there's some pictures of
field work and some machinery used in
that so this is the beginning of may
cover crops going nicely use the dcs
tractor with a rotary plow
in the back which is like a blender
blade and it throws soil up in one
direction you can go six inches deep or
so on a safe rock
with this thing so we put it right into
the cover crop field
and then put a tarp down over it and use
a tremendous amount of sandbags
on the left side see one third of this
field
had not been carved this we let the rye
grow or the whole month and uh
by the end of june that rye had gone to
maturity it was cocky fontaine
forming sea heads and uh so i mowed this
down with a flower mower did a great job
of pulverizing
that ride to the ground and then put
rotary plug for a same day or buy it
especially the next morning
a little bit brown here but the rotary
plug furrows into that that one third of
the field and then on that same day
here's a close-up of what the rotary
club furrow looks like to throw soil up
to one side but it was perfect moisture
at that point it rains all
day
and then that same day we took off the
tarp
so this picture shows a
clear difference between on the right
the two thirds of the fields that have
been parked and the tarp did a really
good job terminating the rye
on the left this is the ride that has
just been mowed a day or so earlier and
then this little swath of green in the
center was the rise that couldn't be
reached by the mower because the plastic
starts right next to it
so here we have now nine furrows and we
planted potatoes into them on the same
day
um dropped them put in half apart
covered with hose
uh and then left it or
um
nearly a month
so this is towards the end of june we
did the first of two weed assessments
and here we just wanted to really see
how the tarp affected the termination of
rye and also
germination germination of some leaves
so summary of these results here here's
the three plots
um
we looked for the percentage is rye
covered and the percent that was covered
with weeds which is anything other than
prior potatoes
uh so
the tarp did a great job of getting rye
getting rid of the rise but the rye was
um prevalent
was abundant in the mulch only spot
which hadn't even been small ship
uh and then there were lots of small
weeds coming up throughout the whole
field
so then
end of june
we used the bcs pillar with a precision
depth roller to cultivate lightly just a
couple inches into soil
uh in the
inter zone planting area so
it um we went through and got rid of a
lot of small weeds the the filler glaze
just scrapes a couple inches and
loosened up the soil that loosens up
soil was then helpful to form the hill
we used hose to heal up all the potatoes
and then mulch two thirds of the supply
and it was mulch fairly thick
so it was like six inches of hay
and um then
it was pretty much on its own until we
started to harvest so here's the picture
of this summer
in uh mulch only
plot
uh it has not been tarped there's a
significant amount of rye coming in but
it doesn't seem to be
that much of a problem
the tarp only plot has a
fairground exposed which is not
something that we would ever generally
do you can see a fine amount of small
weeds coming in and and the best
definitely looks to be the tarp plus
mulch
so and we left a couple more months and
we started the harvest at the end of
september and here's some pictures of
the same three plots
in the end of september and it's the
situation with weeds seems a bit more
dire for sure um
we accept these at this point in the
charcoal we thought we were really
extreme uh
sometimes shading out the canopy of the
potatoes at this point the potatoes
brought the nesting so
ultimately it may not have been that big
of a deal although it made harvesting a
bit more difficult
so we harvested potatoes it went on for
a couple weeks and then we
uh sorted them well cleaned first and uh
and then sorted them to get rid of those
that were
green or maybe chewed by bowls and then
we did a
um well there was a second um
weed assessment here right too before we
started harvesting so summary of the
the weed count here again in the mulch
only spot there's some rye i don't know
how big of a deal that was i think it's
about a year it may be more of a problem
but this is pretty remarkable the
the weed coverage in the tarp only in
the mulch only was pretty high
substantially higher than the tarpon
combination but the amount by which it
increased it was double in the tarp only
in triple mulch only it's pretty
pretty amazing amount of weeds
so we feel pretty confident about the
combination of tarpon mulch together
being the best for weight suppression
throughout the whole season
okay so here's a summary of our our
yield assessment so
um we had three three different
treatments
tarp
only
mulch only tarpon smulch
and then um
i think i didn't mention this earlier
but each plot had three different
varieties we're a little bit concerned
to see how
uh
the the time at which the potatoes
matured into the nest might affect their
yield given the potential the huge
potential for weeds to take over the
field
so we had pontiac red as an early
variety which
uh looking at
these results it it really seemed to
indicate that that potato seed was not
great and we actually grew this variety
in a different field as well and it is
equally as poorly so the two other
varieties the mid-season cute gold and
the late season red maria
both seemed to yield pretty well uh the
cubicle
responded the best to the tarp plus
mulch increase the most
with the combination of those two
soil management practices and the red
maria was all around probably
the best yield
potato
in this but but both of these did best
in the tarp plus mulch
and um
so why this happened we think there were
two things there's there's obviously the
wheat suppression that seems to be set
throughout the whole season and start
plus mulch
but um
also we found that um
that the nitrate the level of soil
nitrate fires when in the tarp
area so um this has been
has been shown in other uh research and
we wanted to see how it played out theta
experiments so we checked nitrate levels
and soils before we put this heart down
in early may and then in june when the
tarp came on
uh so four parts per million before we
put the tarp down it went up just a
little bit the soil warmed up there's
probably some more uh microbial action
happening in there but um this is like
the non-tarp
ground earth plot and the two plus that
were tarps increased maybe almost four
holes so it was a pretty substantial
increase in um
in nitrate in the two positive retards
so if you think the yield
was
primarily due to the nitrate and also
the the suppression sweet
um
i don't have data to show on this but we
had temperature sensors around we did
find that the
the both the min and the max temp uh
of the soil increased throughout the
tarpon period and so that probably
uh assisted with microbial action soil
and also the tarp
probably killed that ride quickly to
reduce nitrogen
tie up due to the cover crop
uh so our answer to this uh question
was uh well should we tarp or mulch or
do both and we think yes to both because
uh in a dry year the mulch should
clearly help with moisture retention the
tarp seems to help with
increasing nitrate leading to a greater
yield
and then both of them in conjunction
seems to do really good at suppressing
these and also to terminate the cover
crop
so
that
is
all that i have to show you today
and ryan are we taking uh questions
yeah we do have time for questions bob
um thank you
any preferred vendors for uh for tarps
bob
how have you sourced your tarps um i got
part at uh
cny cny uh farm supply i think it was in
cortland right you suggested
uh did i give the name of that correctly
um yes
cmy farm supply we're based
in ithaca and you're outside of ithaca
so
[Music]
we lean towards a place where we could
um find them locally through an ag
supplier ask around
yeah you can go pick them up um
on your own they were stuck with sharks
right so like
probably any place that sells dairy
supplies might have on
certainly seems easier than getting a
ship so it wasn't uh it wasn't that hard
to pick up the transport they were
i think 250 dollars for a
32 by 100 foot uh tarp
bob i wonder if you could talk about the
specifics of uh of the weeds in that
field being it being a new field
a lot of perennials and
yeah it was uh it was pretty evident
even the day we took the tarp off that
um it was it's it's mostly perennials
there's a lot of golden rods there's
some milkweed there's some brambles
rubis
uh there was um
a few other
um unusual there's some vetch but mostly
perennial things and even the day we
took the tarp off the the furrows that
had been
made a month earlier had
um
little golden rods coming up in them
seemingly
actively growing which was surprising
they hadn't seen any sun in four weeks
so those things were not that much of a
problem at the beginning of the season
and towards the end they got fairly
large in the recovering
parts of the potatoes so um
they're there in these fields i don't
know that annie will be for much of any
problem at all certainly i think the
combined with mulching it didn't seem
too much of a problem
um but
we don't really weave the plate we're
just throwing potatoes on a pretty low
maintenance style
and and get what we can get out of it
one question from steve is what do you
use for the mulch how do you it sounds
like you source quite a bit of a bomb so
when i get low i i get mulches most
quality hate from some local guys where
i live outside of this because so i have
a
list of several who
often just call me when they get some
hay that gets rained on and they want to
get rid of a couple hundred thousand hay
and uh and i don't have a great way to
store a couple hundred dollars hey we
probably go through nearly a thousand
over the course of the season but
um they'll come by and drop off 50 or
100 at a time and we use it for a couple
weeks or a month and um
i don't think it's don't generally spend
that much money on this doesn't seem
that prohibitive
uh
three dollars a bail at most um
depending on the quantities they buy
and then they deliver if you don't we
don't call that a ourselves
um
so there's always the issue of weeds
coming in with hay but
it hasn't seemed to be that much of a
problem
that was my next follow-up question
ken asks did your treatments have any
impact on insect pests
uh
well surprisingly we didn't i went over
there and scouted probably weekly i
didn't see
i don't think i saw any potatoes there
and not in the same exact spot that we
threw potatoes
nearby nesting fields the year prior to
that so i didn't see any potato beetles
we had no issue to go in there and the
organics for potato people so
um nothing that i could see
it is possible i think mulching probably
has some benefit with the
potato beetle population
but um i don't have any
any data for that
i know you tried to look at voles
because that was an issue
in other
in other farms the use of mulch and gold
what did you find there
um
well there was uh
uh an amount of percentage of potatoes
that were gold shoes it was not
it was not surprising in past years i
don't think we've certainly never
quantitated
that
that well but i think it was something
like five seven percent of the potato
uh harvest was vultured
and it was a little bit higher in the
uh
tarp only no the mulch on the spot sorry
it was a little bit higher in the mulch
only spot i don't know if that was just
because of the mulch on the surface i
tend to think
that the reason why it was the bowl
action was a bit more in the mulch on
the clock was because it was next to it
was close to a fallow part of the field
where it hadn't been mowed
20 feet away there were crashes and
golden rod that were up to your shoulder
by the end of the summer so there's just
probably a greater population of holes
on that edge of the field
um
if it's
i don't know if it was that
big of a difference you know five to
seven fifths at most eight or nine
percent full choose and and we were
being pretty generous about what we
called old shoes
so
i don't think it was too much or wrong i
will say though um
so i took i i mentioned i took the tarp
off the hoop house this past weekend
and as we were rolling up the tarp we
found
there were numerous bowls in there and
and lots of little walnuts with all the
bits of debris
and hay and and then when we got the
plastic out of there they took off out
the sides and i don't know why they
would want to come back in because now
it's just fair grounds the pharisees
planted
and i've done this a bunch of years i
don't think they're going to go back
into that particular hoop house now
they're out in fields somewhere so
it wasn't too much of a problem with the
potato field so
well we've got a couple other questions
here in just a couple more minutes um
was there a difference in labor required
between your treatments
yeah so i didn't show that data because
it gets a little bit um a bit much you
know i wanted to keep this simple but
um we carefully
kept track
of all the time
that we said
every time we went to work on the potato
field
and we also tallied it according to the
different treatments so
the
plots that [ __ ]
had a pretty large amount of labor
investment
uh mulching i don't think that's that
tremendous amount i mean i don't think
you were there more than a couple hours
for the handful of people who mulch that
whole place
and hill at that day too so um tarping
though is a substantial
labor
investment and
it was the first time we had parked on
that large of the scale so we were
particularly concerned about doing it
well on a rented field that was next to
like pretty major road and i could not
risk having that tarp come off so we um
we used um probably way too many uh
sandbags but it was a lot of effort uh
so at any rate we we tallied all the
hours the flavors divided it up into
three different plots and then um
for me it seemed the most uh
interesting was to make a ratio of
the um
the pounds of marketable potatoes per
labor hour investment and and we were
getting something like 17 pounds per
hour
out of the tarp plus mulch plots and
also in the mulch only plots
so the yield and the mulch healthy cloth
is a bunch lower but it also took less
labor hours so
it seemed to work out about even but i
will i will honestly say though i think
that we could probably do that tarping
as half the amount of times if we did
the first time
in that experiment and we did since then
we've moved multiple parts and we're
just way more efficient at it we know
how to do it better
so it's a labor investment and uh and
like everything you've got to practice
it before you feel really comfortable
doing it
right
i do want to honor the time uh we're
about it
um time to switch over to natalie bob
there is a question in there uh from
from deborah about other soils data that
you collected maybe you could pop
some of that
some of your soil's results or at least
what you measured in the chat to answer
that question as we switch over to that
right um yeah it's great to be here i
love following all these excellent
speakers because there's so much
information that now i don't need to
cover
um i know it is kind of the low energy
part of the day though so
i will try to keep it
moving um so shameless plug i'm
surprised ryan didn't actually do this
already but
ryan and i along with a couple
colleagues at the university of maine
just published a tarping guide to the
northeast and it was a real labor of
love
i would encourage you to check it out
you can get it at the just google it you
can find at the university of maine
cooperative extension
[Music]
so the problem with tillage as a primary
weed management strategy i don't want to
spend a lot of time on this but i just
always like to remind people that
tillage
is
okay in small doses but in large doses
it can lead to some very big soil health
problems including poor aggregation
cresting and erosion and increasingly as
john paul and a lot of folks alluded to
this is just not
a good situation in the face of climate
change when we really need that water
holding capacity you never know when
you're going to have a major rain event
etc
um so but managing weeds with less
tillage is a real issue so in order to
do that i think it's really important
that we be thinking about the weed life
cycle
so this is an illustration that is in
the tarping guide if you want to check
it out in more detail
so the weed life cycle for annual weeds
you have this seed bank in the soil and
in any given year if there's the right
conditions some seeds will germinate
and then if you don't take care of them
they will grow and they'll reproduce and
they will add more seeds to your seed
bank
so a lot of weed management is seedling
stage management that includes tillage
herbicides and hand weeding
um
tillage and herbicides being kind of the
big hammers
now seed bank stage management
involves preventing germination and
reducing the size of the seed bank and i
would argue that if we're reducing
tillage we really need to think about
alternative weed management strategies
that are not focused on that seedling
stage management and again john paul had
the story of the the no-till experiment
that was just a ton of hand weeding
which is
not sustainable economically
so small-scale farmers have um come up
with their own low and no-till
strategies for managing weeds uh in 2014
the market gardener was published and
this was kind of the start of the tarp
frenzy i would say so tarping or
occultation as it's known um and that
wasn't really a
no-till but kind of a reduced tillage
strategies but since then we've had this
proliferation of books that farmers have
published case studies on organic
no-till farming and a lot of these case
studies a lot of these farmers rely on
heavy compost
or other sources of mulch
and tarps
um so where do these strategies target
the weed life cycle
well tarps kill existing weeds by
stopping photosynthesis i know that's
really obvious but it's important to to
think about that think about the
mechanism of what's happening and then
they also may encourage fatal
germination of weed seeds we're actually
not really sure what's happening under
the tarps
there's certainly some germination of
seed that's happening but we don't know
if it's really depleting the seed bank
um deep mulch keeps weed seeds from
getting the germination cues that they
need so it essentially just buries the
weed seed bank so it is a seed bank
management strategy
and it's effective but
compost based systems
are kind of problematic i think because
there's a limited supply of compost
it can lead to excess nutrients
especially phosphorus it's expensive
and then this emerging concern i'm from
maine i don't know if you all in new
york are
starting to deal with this but this
emerging concern of pfas
in
various sources of manure
not just not just sludge manure hay etc
so bringing
external inputs onto your farm can be
problematic for contaminants
so can cover crops be
a mulch grown in place
and i mean i think this is not a not a
new concept um as john paul and sarah
talked about this
cover crop based organic rotational
no-till has been around now for quite a
while and they've been refining it for
field crops research using this
roller crimper
but the roller crimper and this scale
doesn't really work for small scale
farms
so
what about cover crops and tarps
the pros of this system include
it's easily accessible equipment a lot
of small farmers have these tarps
roller comfort is not required
there's multiple weed suppression
tactics so instead of just a cover crop
mulch you also have a tarp which is kind
of a big hammer
there are also other benefits of this
system including moisture conservation
and nitrogen dynamics bob mentioned how
these tarps
retain nitrate in the soil by preventing
leaching
and also if you're using a legume cover
cover crop you're fixing quite a bit of
nitrogen and contributing that to your
to your system
the cons of this system
these tarps are plastic
we can talk about that for a long time i
won't i'll just acknowledge that it is
unfortunate that they are plastic
there's also opportunity costs
associated with this system so the cover
crop production period uh can can take
away from your cash crop production
period and the tarping period can also
take away from your cash crop production
period so
you our farmers have to quantify what
that opportunity costs to their to their
individual system and then there's this
question of does this system bring new
weed management challenges like
perennial weeds or um is it selecting
for for different for species that are
resistant to tarpon
so we started doing research on this
back in 2015 which feels like ages ago
now
we did a couple of proof of concept
experiments back when it really felt
like we needed proof of concept now it
feels like everybody's doing this but
back then um it did feel relatively new
and unproven so we did these experiments
we applied tarps in early june in maine
and new hampshire
which i think is probably a little bit
cooler delayed delayed climate compared
to most of you in new york
we transplanted cabbage it was a short
season cabbage variety from johnny's
called tiara
first week of july and then we harvested
cabbage in late august and like i said
we did two separate experiments
and i'm not going to go over the
research results i will just say that
this system works for cabbage which is
fantastic
we published two
two articles on that and you can access
those um but it raised a lot of
questions about whether we can improve
it like it works but uh we think we can
do it better
so
one of the things we wanted to dig into
is this question of opportunity costs
so i calculated
from that from one of those experiments
what were the cumulative degree days
that were used for each period of our
production system
and found so the spring cover crop
growth and this is base four which is
you know a little low but i think that's
appropriate for cabbage and it's
appropriate for cover crops
um
we're using uh you know between four and
500
degree days for the spring cover crop
growth
but then when we tarp for four weeks
almost a month we were using just about
as many degree days for that tarping
period
and then the cabbage itself was using
about twice that um so if you combine
the spring cover crop growth and the
tarping period you could probably
produce a cabbage crop
and is it worth it
what is the best use of your growing
degree days
so that led us to another experiment
uh and we had this question how can we
minimize the opportunity costs and
maximize the benefits so we thought
let's tinker with our termination date
and our tarp duration like there's no
reason why we need to tarp for four
weeks maybe we can really
tighten that up
and see if we can increase the benefits
so we did this experiment this is a
an ariel of our field site in new
hampshire
we seeded our cover crops rye veg
mixture in mid-september which is a
little bit
later than ideal
as john paul mentioned it'd be great if
we could get that in by the beginning of
september but we also wanted to do
something that felt realistic for what
farmers
can actually do and and pushing it
towards the beginning of september um it
just feels like a lot of crops aren't
out of the ground yet so we wanted to to
do something realistic we seeded it
mid-september
and then in the spring
we had three termination dates 10 days
apart in new hampshire those dates were
may 22nd june 1st
and june 12th
and then we had different termination
methods we had glyphosate a 10-day tarp
treatment a 20-day tarp 30-day tarp and
at unh we also had a royal crimp
treatment
so what that looked like that red box
there is a block in our experiment so
that has all of the treatments
um
you can see that it's the in the middle
there is that first termination date so
that the cover crops there were all
terminated on
may 22nd
then t2
you can see there's still one tarp on
that
you can also see the green plot there is
the roll crimp because we did have cover
crop regrowth
um the the plot that still has the tarp
is the 30-day tarp treatment
and then those other three that's the
glyphosate 10-day tarp and 20-day tarp
so that's kind of what it looked like
and you might ask why that's still
pretty late why not the earliest
possible termination dates
and the answer is just that if we
terminated it a whole lot earlier it
wouldn't really be mulch
this is a picture from may 7th and as
you all know you know cover crops really
start to grow
exponentially
in spring and if you terminate them
before that there's just not a lot of
mulch um again that's what it looks like
you know several weeks later
and so this production system just is
not for your earliest season crops not
all production systems are going to fit
all crops
uh we were interested in looking at
different ecosystem services or benefits
including cover crop biomass
quantity and quality cover crop nitrogen
the decomposition and mulch remaining
nitrogen mineralization
and the weed biomass and community
composition
um i am showing you this now because i
this is how after going through some of
the information i'm gonna go through
kind of a visually visualizing these
trade-offs with spider plots and so i'm
going to introduce it now so we can
settle in and then we'll come back to it
so spider plots are a way like i said
visualizing trade-offs and so we've got
at the top here uh cover crop biomass
um
weed suppression is the w m is the mulch
i n is inorganic nitrogen at planting
date and n is the total cover crop
nitrogen so
farther out on the circle is better so
the greatest weed suppression is the
farthest out same with
uh
same with all of the all of their
variables so in this particular example
we have good weed suppression but we
don't have much inorganic nitrogen and
these are all relativized for the
in comparison to the best treatment
so cover crop biomass effects of
termination date
i know this is a lot of pictures but on
the top we've got
our site from maine and moving from left
to right we have
later and later termination dates and
you can see that there's increasing
cover crop biomass you can also see that
there's increasing purple there's
increasing veg in that cover crop
biomass
same on the bottom in new hampshire
and i also wanted to show this because
this is
the
tool that we use in maine so in new
hampshire we had a roller crimper
in maine i did this at my family's farm
we did not have a roller crimper but we
had an awesome john deere riding tractor
and lawn roller which you can get for
about 150 dollars you just fill it with
water
so that does a really nice job of laying
that cover crop down flat
in terms of nitrogen
um
again increasing nitrogen as you get
later even 10 20 days
uh makes a huge difference in the amount
of nitrogen that is fixed by vetch so at
this point
rye has captured accumulated all of the
nitrogen that it will but vetch is
continuing to fix nitrogen and so
there's a pretty big difference between
that first termination date and the last
termination date
um at both uh our main and new hampshire
sites
um and i don't know like ryan if you
wanna stop i'm not checking the chat if
you wanna stalk me at any point with a
question feel free to stop me mid
mid talk
uh otherwise i'll just keep going yeah i
i'm monitoring the chat so we're good to
go right now and then we'll uh
okay
nitrogen mineralization
it was great that
bob mentioned this this has been
observed in multiple studies
that tarps prevent nitrate from leaching
which is great
so we found that for this first
termination date
there was increasing net nitrogen
mineralization with a longer tarp
duration uh which is not surprising it's
nice when you get the results you expect
moving later to the second and third
termination dates very similar pattern
but just an increase
in the actual quantities that we
observed
so tarps prevent
nitrate from leaching longer tarp
duration allows for more nitrogen
mineralization
and delayed cover crop termination
leads to higher nitrogen levels in
organic nitrogen and that could be
because there's just warmer conditions
it's later in the season
and it could also be because there's um
greater cover crop nitrogen going into
that system it's likely a combination of
both
um cover crop biomass mulch and weed
suppression so here you can see what
that uh mulch looks like
um
on the left that's me harvesting the
mulch and the weeds and then on the
right you can see i i put a
i put a
square around that little patch of weeds
to show that that's where i had
harvested
uh mulch previously and just to show
that mulch really does make a difference
in um weeds being able to germinate and
grow
one thing that we did find is that some
perennial weeds are less susceptible to
tarpon cover crops so the whole
part of the weed cycle that i left off
in the beginning is the perennial weed
cycle and anybody who's moving towards
more no-till will find that um
you get to learn a lot more about
perennial weeds and so there's a
in addition to the seed bank there's
also the blood bank
which is the
the perennial
it can be rhizomes it can be nutlets in
this case this is nut grass which is one
of the uh
one of the weeds that we have found is
particularly resistant to tarping so if
you have a yellow nut grass problem
um tarping may not be the answer for you
so getting back to this
visualizing trade-offs with the spider
plots
um
this this experimental design resulted
in
uh sort of five different planting dates
i'm only presenting the data from new
hampshire so the first planning date
june 1st and then the last planting date
july 12th
so here comes a lot of information boom
um i wish i could see your faces i can't
but
what strikes you um so what strikes me
i've spent a lot of time with these data
so i probably see them very differently
than you do but what strikes me
initially is oh wow that that 10-day
tarp on may 22nd that is a small area
you're not getting a lot of ecosystem
services
um then what else strikes me oh but that
30-day tarp
that was terminated on june 12th you are
getting that's a big area you're getting
a lot of ecosystem services
and then the final thing that strikes me
is roller crimping stinks
um you just don't get
in this case it stinks because we didn't
get complete termination of our cover
crop which you know maybe if if it had
been a different
if we had delayed things more we would
have
um but yeah in our climate we just don't
get the
weed suppression and the the efficacy of
termination that we need to make that
system work
um
so i'm going to go through these by
planting date but i'm not going to do
every single planting date i'm just
going to do june 1st june 21st and july
12th so we can digest this a little
better
from the perspective of given a planting
date
what is the best
thing to do so if you are dead set on
planting by june 1st you absolutely have
to get your crops in the ground by june
1st
um
and you're organic you're not going to
use glyphosate okay
you could do the roller crimp
uh it's very ineffective at weed
suppression
or you could use 10 day tarp
you get the earliest planting day but
you're not really maximizing any
ecosystem services
so this system can work but you're
probably going to end up doing quite a
bit of hand weeding as john paul
uh
mentioned happened with their roller
crimping experiment
but then if you move to june 21st if you
can delay
your crop planting
and here we get the benefit of being
able to look at the a 10-day tarp
duration a 20-day tarp duration and a
30-day tarp duration
um and so we can look across those but
these are all ending up as a planting
date of june 12th
and we can see that at this point
weed suppression is optimized for all
treatments
but a longer tarp duration so this
30-day tarp terminated on may 22nd
does result in greater inorganic
nitrogen on the at the planting date
but
delayed cover crop termination leads to
greater
cover-up biomass total nitrogen and
mulch
so the question is what is most valuable
to you if you really want to get your
cover if you want to get your crop in
the ground on june 21st is it more
valuable for you to have a little bit
more inorganic nitrogen do you actually
prefer not to have quite as much mulch
then maybe you could do a 30-day tarp
and terminate it earlier but if you want
more mulch if you want more biomass you
want more total nitrogen
then delaying termination
is probably better
and then finally if you're willing to
wait until july 12th
to plant your crop you get a ton of
ecosystem services you maximize all eco
system services but your planting date
is really delayed
so
again it just comes back to this
question of what is most valuable to you
these are trade-offs there's no perfect
system
and
what works for you
so conclusions
um cover crop based no-till with tarps
works it's especially good for fall
breasts because this is a picture from
evening song farm in vermont and they
are one of the case studies featured in
our tarpon guide
and they've adopted this for their fault
brassicas they've even been tinkering
with a
planting tool to make transplanting a
little bit easier
and they've found that this has really
become an integral part of their
cropping system for those fall brassicas
most ecosystem services are maximized by
delaying cover crop termination
and that's especially true when hairy
vetch is included it has a delayed
maturity compared to rye
i don't know a lot about austrian winter
pea i would be curious to to know if
that's similar for austrian winter pea
or if you can get those
get that nitrogen earlier i
tend to think that austrian winterpeat
just doesn't
fix quite as much nitrogen period
the exception to that is inorganic
nitrogen at planting date is increased
with longer tarp duration so if that's
your primary goal then tarping for a
longer period
may be better
so
um future work can experiment with
different
cover cropping and cropping sequencing
sequences um possibly even shorter tarp
durations uh like a couple days
um in summer
so i think there's a lot of work to be
done but just the difference between
when we started this in 2015 and it felt
like we actually applied for
um
we got a research for novel approaches
grant from northeast sare
and now when i think about this this is
not a novel approach at all anymore no
one would say this is novel because
people are doing it um so we've come a
long way and i think that's pretty cool
natalie are you familiar with other with
some farms growing other crops in here
other than than brassica crops john paul
talked about experimenting with winter
squash or just think about those
trade-offs and identifying the different
crops that might work at those different
times
you know folks that are growing things
other than nebraska's at different time
frames
i don't
but
yeah there's a lot of
potential
one question is about uh shorter tarping
times for hot summer weather use any
more thoughts
yeah i think that um you could do
shorter times i also think that you
could do
clear tarps for just a few days at a
time solarizing can really cook things
so if it is the the
peak of summer
i would encourage trying clear tarps for
just a few days
how do you have your hand up did you
want to ask a question
yeah
thanks ryan um i was just hoping to ask
it versus type it in um be easier um
nice presentation i was just curious um
if you have been
dealing with any kind of
any issues with you know weather
variability unpredictability kind of as
we're seeing
changes in when rainfall happens or dry
periods are has this been
impacting or are you seeing any
differences
over the years that you've been doing
this tarping work in in the region you
are in terms of the length of time
tarping and cover cropping may be most
effective
i would say
that the big the big thing is um
we used to have more wet springs
back when i was a kid um
and now we end up sometimes with dry
springs and so in a wet spring tarping
is fantastic because it keeps the
the soil moisture kind of constant and
so you can
it doesn't get saturated
it drains the field capacity and then
you pull the tarp off and it's ready to
go
now if you have a dry spring and you
don't have irrigation cover crops can
actually suck up that water
and
you can have a very dry soil when you
put the tarp on if you don't irrigate
and tarping is not as effective it's not
really effective at all for weed control
it will terminate the cover crop but it
won't provide you with a lot of
additional weed control if the soil is
dry
so i do think that's a risk i wouldn't i
would say don't don't tarp a dry soil um
either irrigate or look at the weather
and
try to work around it um but
yeah
i don't know if that happens thank you
natalie uh one question is about a
wheelerpath does the little pathway of
cry rear its own head at all
for a cash crop for a subsequent
cash crop i don't know we only did
transplants
um so i mean allelopathy of rye would be
great for weed seeds bad for
you know
lettuce uh
and i've never direct seeded lettuce
into it but i also have a feeling that
with this long
it with a longer tarping period i don't
think the allelopathic compounds are
active for very long
i can't say that for sure but
i think if you are cover cropping for a
couple weeks
i would guess it would not be as intense
but i also would i would caution against
direct seeding very susceptible
crops
this is we're still in like a
um
transplant or very
very hardy
seed like beans
that's the next stage of novelty i guess
right
yeah direct seeded crops
thanks natalie
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu